sully sur loire ce matin le fleuve et au
mais rien de bien alarmant
plus en aval à jargeau même constat et
les promeneurs que nous rencontrons ne
sont pas franchement inquiet je les
connais elle était soulagée la route la
wii c'est à dire qui a touché le lemur
donc là aucune inquiétude pour vous non
il ya quinze jours elle était plus haute
que ça donc je viens voir ça tous les
matins on guette et là on constate que
cette nuit ça n'a pas trop monter le
niveau de la loire et donc scruté de
près par les riverains
un peu plus loin à saint denis en val
jacques martin et sait de quoi il parle
lui aussi monsieur le maire connaît par
coeur l'histoire du fleuve
ici en 2003 nous avions les pieds dans
l'eau jusqu'à mes pieds mais piété dans
l'eau donc nous sommes encore assez loin
d'accord mais faut être vigilant tout
les chansons à fleur d'eau plus rien ne
coule plus rien c'est cool donc à un
moment donné ça va coincer à la
direction régionale de l'environnement
on surveillait également le niveau des
cours d'eau mais surtout le débit des
affluents de la loire pour ce
prévisionniste la situation est normale
pour l'instant ce sont des crues
hivernales typiques sont des crues qu'on
a une chance de rencontrer
de une sur deux chaque année donc c'est
à dire que en moyenne c'est ce sont des
crues qu'on voit une année sur deux on
attend demain 5 à 10 mm d'eau on parle
ensuite d'un temps beaucoup plus sec
ce week-end la pluie devrait faire à
nouveau son apparition mardi prochain on
parle de fortes précipitations
mais il s'agit d'une date beaucoup trop
éloigné pour qu'on puisse en mesurer
réellement l'impact sur les sols et les
cours d'eau